[Music]
this is brain freeze motorsport racing
sponsored by please welcome to the
challenge this race is gonna be tougher
because of the nature of the track the
track is more technical you will guys
need to use more than racing line
especially braking technique you have
two corners with a lot of banking so you
gotta keep a lot of momentum through
these corners and then you have a slower
corner which is tighter maybe third year
and I have to be better on the brakes
think you have an advantage because if
you are is really really real and
straight but in the other hand you can
use the brakes from the other car and
take advantage of that so it's gonna be
a really tight way is really equal and
let's see who wins
so this race is a grid start what's the
difference between that and the rolling
start this one is more about traction
how you put traction down to the surface
so when you go on the throttle there's
two techniques one is short shifting
okay when you're start having wheel spin
on the wheels which means you shift to
second gear earlier or the other one is
lake the Theroux to look for some
traction and then go back on the
throttle again between those techniques
I would use the throttle to me all right
good luck guys
here we go I feel like this is a
gentleman's sport and I don't see why
you have to be you know shouting at the
other guy you're like yeah you should be
polite you should both be appreciative
you know
so let's maintain our dignity as we
drive each other into the dirt
how's that feel sounds great all right
let's you look
[Music]
alright well we already know ok so to be
clear you had the faster car right so
hey no video no excuses remember be a
gentleman
don't that's not very gentlemanly let
think I might like a they're going out
crushing this coating ice or they're
gonna crush one too
oh I like the line from James and you
really pull away any straightaways all
right I'm gonna try and keep a little
bit more power in this one so I can't
lose this speed
there we go
James is closing up a mistake mistake
from Brian
[Applause]
there we go okay now take it on the
straight and I'm creeping up right Anya
why is he looking straight okay here we
go oh boy he came out of nowhere
nice break here from Ryan oh he's coming
up on me now keep the walk real fast
he's got it come on
for much from their eggs too much human
breaks it told you flashing once so I
know you're breaking
last lap last lap oh boy this close very
contact by Sir accounts
this is my turn coming up
well that was nice you took that real
nice last turn
Brian keeps saying said he just
overshoot the Carvey it's gonna be tight
you're gonna take this one ah I'm the
gt-r Warren I was too busy worrying
about you in the back hey that was
pleasant you made me proud because you
were driving the GTR okay guys congrats
that race was really really tight was
nerve-racking at the end it really
really close racing which I like always
some contact as well GT race it's
allowed to have some contact so nice job
also Ryan you put the GTR on top so I'm
proud of you some advices that you can
guys use especially in this kind of
racing it's to use the rough racing you
gotta go behind the car in front and
then you get the tow in so you can
overtake them on the straights you could
have actually used it at the end James
maybe try to catch the ETR with this
iron dynamic stop and yeah let's see
Ryan if you can win the next one against
Lawrence from the semi-finals man good
luck yeah gonna need it yeah